[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invitaron a vuelta
al mundo de la mano de nuestra red de
periodistas se cumplen seis meses desde
el inicio de la invasión de rusia a
ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr zielinski ha prometido que su
país retomará el control total de la
península de crimea anexada por rusia en
2014 diciendo que allí donde todo
comenzó todo terminará mientras tanto
moscú continúa con sus avances
asegurando que los objetivos de su
llamada operación militar especial serán
alcanzados tras la invasión de rusia
miles de mujeres jóvenes se alistaron
para servir en el ejército ucraniano y
ahora están plenamente integradas en las
fuerzas armadas una organización
benéfica recauda fondos para que puedan
recibir el equipamiento que necesitan y
nuestro equipo en el terreno paso un día
con ellas el siguiente es un informe de
robert version melina y bebe y ride abu
zeid
antes del comienzo de la guerra dura
trabajaba en el negocio de la moda ahora
utiliza sus antiguos conocimientos para
recaudar fondos para las mujeres del
ejército pero su uniforme no es sólo
para mostrar es lo que lleva cada día en
el frente donde vive en las mismas
condiciones que los hombres
2007 son 16 y no es chile
fue 4 kph hay que saber hacer de todo
conducir camiones militares y cavar
trincheras es el ejército no se hacen
excepciones con nosotras
hay que estar preparada para todo
archivo libre en 2014
pero el ejército ucraniano no estaba
preparado para una incorporación tan
grande de mujeres carece de equipamiento
diseñado para las mujeres soldados ahora
espera que esta sesión de fotos con
zemliaski ayude a cambiar eso una parte
de los beneficios de la venta de joyas
se destinará a la compra de equipamiento
pues en el fútbol ganar y aún así es de
que cajón y es parte hemos encontrado
patrocinadores que nos están apoyando
con ayuda humanitaria algunos están
comprando uniformes otros placas para
chalecos antibalas cuestan mucho dinero
y los cascos tienen que ser más ligeros
y pequeños no son fáciles de encontrar
además de productos de higiene y ropa
interior femenina se envía aquí ya ha
suministrado 300 chalecos antibalas para
mujeres que luchan en el frente
de
estas placas pesan menos de 3 kilos pero
dan una protección similar a las que
proporciona el ejército que pesan 5
kilos así que la protección es igual de
buena y son el doble de las heras
de tejido cupo de armas
pero semillas que sabe que tiene que
intensificar sus esfuerzos con la
llegada del invierno se calcula que
50.000 mujeres van a necesitar uniformes
especialmente diseñados para el frío los
últimos soldados franceses que quedaban
en gao en mali se han retirado de su
base para dirigirse hacia el vecino
níger el ejército francés había estado
en ese país durante nueve años como
parte de la llamada 'operación baja que
han desplegando hasta dos mil 400
soldados en esa nación sin embargo en
febrero el presidente emmanuel macrón
anunció el retiro de sus tropas tras el
incremento de las tensiones con la junta
militar que se hizo con el poder en 2020
el siguiente es un informe de españa y
carolyn lámbarri
fue el último contingente de soldados
franceses de la operación marcan el
lunes tomaron sus pertenencias y se
marcharon tras las crecientes tensiones
con la junta gobernante la operación de
9 años deja un variado legado pero por
ahora los soldados que parten se
concentran en el peligroso viaje que
tienen por delante tienen sólo unos días
para mover cientos de piezas de equipos
y llevarlas a la base francesa en níger
la llegado debe ser entregada al
ejército maliense así que se van en unas
horas porque dejamos este lugar de
operaciones en unas horas
cómo se siente
como podría decirlo está completo
nuestra misión aquí se ha completado es
muy importante que nos vayamos todos
juntos y con buena salud
con los años la influencia del grupo
estado islámico se ha expandido en el
lado maliense de la frontera con níger
el 7 de agosto 42 soldados valientes
murieron en un ataque yihadista en tesis
mientras se retiran los soldados
franceses prefieren evitar hablar de
política el sentimiento de frustración
es evidente
cuando eres un soldado no puedes pensar
en las decisiones políticas que toma
nuestro gobierno tenemos una misión y
nuestro único objetivo es esa misión no
se pueden mezclar estas cosas
mira bajar esos
sólo quedan unos pocos vehículos en la
base pronto desaparecerán y con ellos la
presencia del ejército francés en el
país
china se ve afectada por una crisis
multidimensional ésta incluye la amenaza
de desplome de su sector inmobiliario
impactado por las deudas el golpe de los
efectos climáticos con poderosas
inundaciones y sequías y por supuesto
los confinamientos que se mantienen bajo
la política de 'cero kobe del gobierno
entre los recientemente afectados están
los turistas que visitaron la isla de
hainán más de 100.000 de ellos quedaron
atrapados en los balnearios y esto fue
parte de lo que vivieron veamos el
informe de luxe la actual mujer y jan
chan
problemas en el paraíso después de que
los casos de coronavirus se dispararán
en la isla de hainán hace dos semanas
los hoteles de lujo se han convertido en
centros de aislamiento a pesar de las
protestas de sus clientes
hay una protesta creo que se debe a que
once miembros del personal han dado
positivo en la prueba de covite por lo
que la gente quiere marcharse del hotel
fairmont y nueva soccer pero no pueden
irse el gobierno ha puesto barricadas en
el local con estrecha vigilancia
policial por el momento
esto da mucho miedo este expatriado de
reino unido ha estado esperando estas
vacaciones durante dos años pero ahora
no puede salir de su habitación y el
hotel en el que estamos es muy lujoso
así que bastante caro así que hemos
ahorrado durante mucho tiempo para venir
aquí es devastador que no podamos ya
sabes podemos mirarlo pero no podemos
tocarlo no lo podemos tocar así que si
un poco deprimente en realidad y el
ciclo se repite caos en los aeropuertos
y la aparición de más hospitales de
emergencia y centros de pruebas
todas las mañanas tenemos que hacer cola
para una prueba de pcr justo al lado de
la playa este hombre es libre de salir
de la casa en la que vacaciona pero la
vida normal se ha detenido bruscamente a
su alrededor
todo está cerrado es difícil encontrar
comida
hace solo dos meses cuando estaba
encerrado en shanghai esperaba
compensarlo con unas vacaciones en jaén
and
fue un infierno en shanghai como puedes
imaginar así que volver a pasar por todo
eso psicológica y físicamente es muy
duro así que mi reacción fue encontrar
la manera de tomar un vuelo para salir
de aquí rápidamente
pero la isla estuvo aislada del mundo
durante 10 días todos los vuelos
cancelados mientras vuelven a ponerse en
marcha lentamente esta turista vuelve
por fin a casa a shanghai una vez allí
le espera otra cuarentena
[Música]
espero que no tengamos más problemas y
aterrizamos en shanghai a partir de ahí
nos llevarán a un hotel de cuarentena y
nos harán la prueba de pcr y si es
negativa podremos finalmente volver a
casa
en casa o de vacaciones china vive bajo
la amenaza constante de nuevos cierres
por un pequeño número de casos todo por
una política de 'cero covite
grupos defensores de los derechos de la
minoría cristiana en india han reportado
un aumento en los ataques contra quienes
profesan esta religión en el país
asiático hechos que se han manifestado
desde la violencia verbal hasta la
destrucción de iglesias e incluso
asesinatos los cristianos representan
aproximadamente un 2 por ciento de la
población india su situación ha
empeorado en los estados dirigidos por
el bj penn el partido nacionalista del
primer ministro narendra modi veamos el
informe que nos han enviado nayla kahn y
mário la uam
bajo esta carpa en mi ruta tres horas de
delhi el pastor a hi kumar celebra una
misa todos los domingos pero durante los
últimos meses teme ser atacado por dar
sermones
en 2021 fue encarcelado solo por
practicar su religión
la policía me acusó de convertir a la
gente al cristianismo también dijeron
que había recibido mucho dinero para
convertir a la gente y por eso me
arrestaron luego en la comisaría dijeron
que me habían arrestado bajo la ley 151
por perturbar la paz pública
los cristianos son una minoría en la
india y representan un poco más del 2%
del total de 1400 millones de personas
en el país aunque los cristianos han
vivido en la india desde el siglo 4 en
los últimos años la discriminación
contra la comunidad va en aumento una
aldea no podría alzar su voz para
vencernos mañana y todos los demás
podrían ponerse de pie con él así que
estamos asustados
en 2020 varios estados indios incluidos
uttar pradesh implementaron una ley
contra la conversión con el objetivo de
prohibir las conversiones religiosas en
agosto otro estado himachal pradesh
enmendó su ley para castigar a los
culpables de conversión masiva con hasta
10 años de prisión
para hyundai al experto en minorías
religiosas estas leyes pretenden
promover la agenda nacionalista hindú
del partido que actualmente gobierna el
bj p
de empagua empoderan a las fuerzas anti
nacionales a los grupos anti populares a
los grupos fundamentalistas
y de hecho se vuelve como un silbato
para perros que dice que es un juego
justo atacar y posiblemente matar a
cristianos y musulmanes que están
redactando la nueva constitución de la
india para el estilo de vida que se
practica en india ford en draft apenas
el año pasado más de 300 personas fueron
atacadas por grupos extremistas hindúes
por acusaciones de conversión forzada en
todo el país una de esas víctimas es el
pastor que local y antes fue golpeado en
las calles de la capital nueva delhi
mere puedas ver yo había puesto arma
para este es el vídeo del 25 de febrero
donde me golpearon la gente me amarró
las manos
algunas me dieron puños y otros me
patearon me arrepiento de este día
siempre voy a estar preocupado por lo
que pasó ese día yo presenté una
denuncia pero la policía no ha tomado
medidas
y por eso no hay ninguno
los grupos de derechos humanos de
cristianos han condenado los crecientes
crímenes de odio contra la comunidad el
16 de agosto durante una audiencia en la
corte suprema del gobierno indio negó
cualquier ataque dirigido contra
cristianos
a ustedes muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsables nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en france 24 tras 24
punto com